this
[ __ ] part 2
no i'm just kidding please don't fire me
tony
i'm doing a good one i'm one of the good
ones
uh i know what i look like but uh i'm
not that into anime
which is unfortunate because the only
women who are attracted to me are pretty
into anime
it's like the whole thing i forgot to
have wrestling anime face
i'm on a date like oh you're like an
anime how many brothers and sisters do
you have
where did you go to college
and then i get laid with an anime day
which is where you pass out holding
hands
uh but yeah i love being asian as a man
you know it's kind of difficult as an
asian man because democratization women
are beautiful not everyone thinks asian
men are beautiful
how do you think asian women are created
[Applause]
be [ __ ] i'm a crucial part of the
sexy process
please stop trying to skip me if you
have sex with me our children will be
very beautiful
half of them so that half will be great
engineers and that's important too
but a lot of asian women act like
they're hotter than asian men but we
look exactly the same [ __ ]
i can throw on a wig and be a seven
why are you bragging they can [ __ ] white
dudes i can [ __ ] white dudes
looking awful
um i i am single i have yet to meet my
soul mate i begin to think
maybe it's her fault she needs to get
out more
she seems like a loser
i think i can do better my friends are
like dude hans you need to learn how to
talk to women
maybe or maybe women should learn how to
listen to hans
[Applause]
why don't you want to hear about the
federal reserve
where the part
did you know that because my vagina can
make a baby my vagina is technically a
3d printer
i was like actually your womb is a 3d
printer
vagina is a tray
[Applause]
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
it takes nine months to print and the
whole time is printing is complaining
[Applause]
needless to say i did not say any
printer trays that night
but i'm glad that women give birth
because i feel like if men gave birth
we'd be like bro i've been eating so
much protein and creatine during my
pregnancy
this baby's like 27 pounds ready bro
check out the six-pack of the ultrasound
thought about those gains in the first
trimester
i don't think i could ever [ __ ] a dude
i've never looked at a beautiful woman
i've been like wow is there a version of
her that's bigger and hairier and has
less kindness
i want to put that inside me
never happened straight as [ __ ]
please believe me my dad does this
my dad's like dude can you imagine being
gay that means most of the gender that
you're attracted to wouldn't be
attracted to you back
i was like whoa can't even imagine
i was crying a lot those gays
uh i don't understand people who say
it's adam and eve not adam and steve
because adam and eve were not a good
couple biblically
first of all they disobeyed god and they
ate a fruit they weren't supposed to eat
which is kind of gay
and then they raised cain and abel and
cain murdered abel why are we taking
parenting advice from people who raised
a murderer
there are only three other people on
earth to kill a quarter of the world's
population
um but uh my sister has uh
just got back from a mission trip if you
don't know that as a mission trip is
when americans go to the rural countries
to get new profile pictures
really good photo shoots um
i i'm an atheist now because i'm not a
kindergarten and i have an internet
[Applause]
connection
i think it'd be stressful to have an
ideology that can be destroyed by facts
oh look a fossil [ __ ]
i guess i could have been blowing dudes
this whole time
not gay
but uh yeah i mean uh sex is pretty cool
i
uh i have a hard time with sex because
99 of my sex career was solo
and now i have to have an orgasm while
someone's breathing on me
i know what my name is you have to keep
saying it
i'm getting my glasses all foggy
where's my office chair i'm gonna come
it's pavlovian i need all his chairs to
come now
but um i i get called a premature
ejaculator a lot which
is my feelings because premature to who
i came right at the perfect time when i
felt amazing
it takes maturity to not please yourself
but i used to date this woman who was
really into yoga and chuck sex and i was
like do you enjoy breathing
or not
[Applause]
pick up your mind millennial
well the ladies um i uh
i think it's weird that uh tanner is a
white person's name
tanner than what you white [ __ ]
she'll be like hey this is my mexican
friend tanner
that's my black friend tanist
i am not a racist i'm a minority how
could i be impossible
i don't even see race i only smell it
i i was on an airplane once and i saw a
dude reading a book in arabic which kind
of freaked me out
but then it's a pull the corner of the
page and put the book away and i was
like oh thank god he's got future plans
only an idiot would blow themselves up
in the middle of the book
i would have to say that my favorite
marvel movie is the black panther
because it gave black children a hero
that can finally look up to
and not just someone like martin luther
king jr malcolm x or harriet tubman
durgan marshall george washington carver
milan rosa parks nelson mandela
[Music]
[Applause]
now there's a fake person that dresses
like a cat
you made it
i'm just jealous when are they gonna
come out with a yellow panda huh
the [ __ ] where's our movie man i love
being asian or that i've known this
country
chinese i'm from a province in china
called south korea
it's gonna be here in texas because i'm
also a southerner like you guys i'm from
south korea
there's only two things i like shooting
commies in k-pop
[Applause]
my asian friends make fun of me because
i like to eat general service chicken
they're like monsters in general says
chicken just a shitty americanized
version
something authentically asian i was like
yeah but so am i
my favorite movie is rush hour 3.
i love rednecks because they can survive
in any wilderness situation that you put
them in
except a situation where everyone has
equal rights
kind of [ __ ] them up you can live in a
swamp with an alligator why can't limit
a cul-de-sac with a minority
but that was my time thank you guys so
much